quite a consistent player in that regard
compared to maybe some of his more
versatile rivals and wow the queen's
gambit declined but it's a really really
trendy variation black now creating
maximum tension in the center all these
four pawns looking at each other and
yeah magnus he's played this one with
the black pieces recently quite a lot
he's also faced this one when he's had
white and uh this opening seems to be in
every player's repertoire these days of
anchor yeah it certainly does i was
actually looking at this morning i was
discussing it uh with someone and uh
i have to say though i mean it's what i
really like about ding is that he's a
player who believes in his openings and
he's had some epic battles in an
opening variation called the catalan
with magnus they've like played out like
at least five or six times been a lot of
draws and uh ding is it's like yeah
bring it on i want to repeat the same
thing but it's magnus that varies and
i'm predicting here that uh doing
maybe just to keep things fluid might
just push his kick he actually played it
just when i was about to say it i was a
bit long-winded there and uh yeah push
the king's born forward and just keep
things flexible yeah all other options
for white would have resulted in
exchanges just the position kind of uh
simplifying liquidating itself the
central pawns would have all disappeared
but ding is just trying to keep maximum
attention and this is quite good uh in
general at least for us spectating but
also for ding
keeping as many pieces on the board as
possible keeping the position tense and
hoping for chances later in the game uh
i think magnus just the fact that he
played this opening so quickly he would
have been
studying this opening beforehand he
would have been rehearsing all of the
small details figuring out how black can
equalize in the opening but with his
choice here ding it has had at least now
made the world champion think
and uh choices for black would include i
was going to say pushing this pawn
forward i think most likely black could
have also brought out the knight and now
we see a trade of pawns in the center
and
very very similar pawn structure
actually ivanka to the first game today
just with colours reversed we have
almost an identical pawn structure and
that means black might well get
weaknesses
that might even get an isolated pawn but
white now developing very quickly i
think ding is going to castle kingside
uh bring his king to safety much quicker
than magnus did in the previous game
that is the big difference and now it's
up to black to decide how to clarify the
structure in the center and also how to
get the black king
also to safety yeah and there's kind of
also the pressing issue is like do you
develop your dark squared bishop do you
capture the pawn in the middle of the
board
the reason why there's a bit of
hesitation as to what to do is because
if you do develop your dark squared
bishop you might be obliged to waste
some time say for instance white then
captures the pawn you're like oh i have
to capture the pawn again and i've lost
time in my
bishop i i have just checked in the
database i can see that magnus has
actually played this particular
variation with the black pieces in a
banter blitz against uh anish giri and
that result
the draw it was in the banter blitz cup
final ah
so a couple of years ago
and uh yeah magnus so he's familiar with
this position but he's spending a bit of
time
maybe he's just thinking
ding possibly has studied that game in
the past i don't think ding has but uh
you never know and magnus he wants to be
creative at this early stage it's all
about at the top level surprising your
opponent in the opening even if it's
just a tiny move order change even if
it's just maybe a slight
different kind of setup from your
previous games that's what it's all
about and magnus he's the master at
finding ways to avoid his opening his
opponent's opening preparations so
yeah i think he's going to move one of
the black bishops or maybe capture the
pawn in the center but uh if you move
the bishop where and if you want to move
a bishop which one a lot of choice for
black
and as your banker says the dark square
bishop wants to move but if you move it
now you lose a bit of time
over the next few
next few times so okay really tense
again psychological opening battle from
these two players neither side actually
trying to win right from the start not
really trying to punish the opponent in
the opening they're just trying to get a
playable position
and okay as uh ivanka mentioned one of
the options trade a set of pawns and
when night uh when the white knight
recaptures which is most likely here
then the black dark squad bishop can
just come out in one go and black can
castle the king away to safety i don't
think ding will capture with this pawn
here because then the pawn structure
will be just too symmetrical
yeah i would say as well i i would be
surprised if that move were even popular
but it is but it is i was going to say
and it's been played by players such as
mama jaroff and
um yilmaz a famous grandmaster from
turkey so it does have its uh advocates
okay i must admit that's a new one for
me
i'm learning something already in this
opening stage that's that's always good
and uh the pawn structure being
symmetrical at least does favor white
slightly because white is ahead in
development when pawn structures are
completely balanced like this it's all
about who has the most time who can get
the pieces to active squares first and
white is actually two moves ahead in
development while it's already moved the
light squared bishop and white has
castled the king away it takes back two
moves to do that uh to play copycat so
ding has two moves in his pocket over
the next few turns to actually try and
create some
some threats
yeah and whilst we're waiting for magnus
to come up with a move um i wanted to
share with you some selfies and uh
ferdinand bucking florida sends us
greetings from switzerland i
really like the scene we had switzerland
chicago we've had many countries in
mexico yesterday
love it and uh johnny slaw actually
actually has a question for you david he
asks
who is your favorite opponent oh
interesting
that's really tricky there's two ways to
answer that question who's my favorite
opponent that i like to win against
and the other one is who's my favorite
opponent to maybe test myself
oh that's a really good question i've
never thought of it maybe my favorite
opponent now is uh magnus age 10 on the
yeah
but um yeah i mean i really really
enjoyed uh playing against as strong
players as possible just to push myself
to learn a few things
then again i did enjoy my match maybe
just a couple of weeks ago against
nilsgrandelias yeah we hadn't actually
played each other too much before that
we'd studied chess together we're good
friends but um i learned so much ten
games we played in ten days and
uh i learned an enormous amount and yeah
and what about who's your favorite
opponent to win against
you do you play and then you always have
i always get away with it you have a bad
position doesn't matter you turn it
around you win
hi simon
okay no um oh that's tricky uh i don't
wanna name names how about you ivanka is
your favorite opponent
um who's my favorite opponent
yeah i like you like you i i do like the
players who test you um one of the
players you know i really enjoy playing
against him he's a good friend of mine
it's actually grand master um stewart
conquest i really enjoy our games
because i feel like he's giving me a
mental workout because i can't figure
out any of his moves
he's super creative yeah totally and
those kind of players i really enjoy
because you just you feel like you have
to be in tip-top shape even though
even though the positions themselves
when you look back on it they might not
seem that energetic or whatever you just
get this very intense sensation at the
board
nice
meanwhile a couple of moves in this game
so black has indeed castled and it's
very very symmetrical apart from the
fact that white has a knight planted in
the middle of the board in black's half
as well and that's very annoying i don't
think magnus ever wants to go and
capture that night because that knight
will be just replaced by a very strong
pawn
and actually white is the one who
initiates that exchange i'm slightly
surprised he rushed with that but then
again black does have a shattered pawn
structure on the left side of the board
especially black's a pawn now is an
isolated pawn and the black sea pawn
that has just moved a backward pawn so
in terms of strategic
differences white has maybe the more
healthy pawn structure but then again
the position has clarified in the center
and black if he's accurate should be
okay in this type of structure and uh
okay magnus offering a trade of bishops
just why not that bishop was slightly
passive and white's bishop the dark
square ship was on an active diagonal
and ivanka who do you tend to prefer
these pawn structures
white white uh you know i'm like a dog
with a bone if you give me this
type of position you know
backward porn i'm gonna
attack that pawn for the rest of his
days and try and pile up pressure and
one of the things that i really like to
do is i like to utilize this concept
that was
i think coined by nimcovich although i
don't know whether it's he's the source
but it's just basically you control you
restrain and you destroy so first of all
you control that pawn so you start
attacking it then yep and then you start
restraining it by that you stop it from
advancing and then you destroy which
basically means that you pile up as many
of your pieces as possible because that
that target has been immobilized and
then you enjoy the fruits of all your
hard work and you win that material yeah
and actually we predicted the moves they
have happened and uh in this position
black actually has two weak pawns as
well this one is isolated and it's kind
of being stared at by white's bishop uh
so that keeps the black rook passive
magnus decided to move that pawn at
least now his rook is free to kind of
centralize itself later on and ding
kind of just occupying the uh the square
in front of the backwood pawn very
logical as well as your anchor mentioned
you want to attack it you want to
restrain it first though and this is one
good way of restraining the pawn white's
knight is just glorious it can never be
removed from the square
the only way is to actually trade it off
as black but then you lose some of your
dynamic potential if you trade off the
knights
so magnus wants to play with pieces
instead keeping the tension and over the
next few turns i expect to see ding try
to build up as yumanka mentioned against
this pawn this could involve for example
stepping the queen forward maybe lifting
the rook up to the third rank and
doubling up the rooks on this c file
stacking them up long term this is the
big target and the reason i like this
move as well with the white queen
okay he hasn't gone for this yet but uh
you just keep an eye on this weakness
it's all about isolated pawns yes white
has one too in the central board but
this is never really weak it's easily
defended uh so ding just playing copycat
black centralized his rook on an open
file and he has done the same if
everything gets traded off these two
pawns are going to be eternally weak
magnus needs to keep the queens on
though and uh that's not normally his
style normally he likes to head to the
end game this time he really can't that
only favors the thing
all right well remember they are tied
these two after a first very long game
so the only thing about that very long
game is that it's getting even later for
dingley ren now it's going to be
way past
2 o'clock in the morning and
sorry this game or this match will go on
for a long time to the early early
morning and
china i just like that tweet vamanos
david
i have to say there's been a lot of love
and cheer for david everyone's very
proud that he beat magnus age 10. uh we
were all feeling it with you david
i just feel guilty i kind of screamed at
the end and i hope nobody was listening
with uh headphones because i might have
defined a few people i'm sorry about
that oh but we love that sports reaction
and obviously in chess over the board
that's uh not very positive have you
ever been able to celebrate like that
and over the world chess ah it's
possible i guess i tend not to i tend to
kind of shake my hand be respectful to
the opponent and then go back to my
hotel room and either scream in
excitement or disappointment so we
actually have we actually have the
reaction take a look at this
oh that is just pure joy i love it
look at
that it's pretty sad that i'm getting
this excited about beating a 10 year old
on an app
but it is the world champion
yes ever david you did it with three
seconds to spare as well you know so it
was just such a perfect game you know
living life on the edge you know you
know he was smoothly winning and then
messed up a little bit kept us all on
our toes and then we were then it became
a matter of counting and then then he
did it he found the right way and it was
too quick
and then it was just a case of beating
the clock so it had the whole storyline
this could be like the next hollywood
movie oh yeah david against
magnus
it's been training every single day
netflix ever run out of uh story ideas
but yeah there's one bad habit of mine
it's always i call it brinksmanship it's
always like on the edge three seconds
yeah just in time and
it's not good for the heart but
it does feel like a sport that way
and uh meanwhile just one move white's
queen improving itself as mentioned just
keeping her eyeline on both sides of the
board one of the advantages of online
chess is that the clock is really
apparent meanwhile when you're playing
over the board chess sometimes it's not
really clear whether you've made
the next time control or not
and i once had a case with one of my
students and he didn't know whether they
had added time so he started blitzing
and blitzing and blitzing and then he
thought he'd
check mated with like seconds to spare
and he was like
and then everyone turned around to him
you do realize there was a second time
in control
he was like oh okay
that's why we write moves down sometimes
yeah people ask me why you write the
moves down firstly for our own records
but secondly you might get out of time
after a certain number of moves yeah and
it's important to check time control
magnus
in norway chess one year right he forgot
to check the regulations and he actually
lost some time
yeah he let his time run out he thought
he was about to receive an extra 30
minutes but nope nope yeah i remember
everyone was
everyone was watching this on live tv
and and everyone's gonna move
make a move and there he was just yes so
calm settling into this long thing i
remember i commented on that game for tv
to norway and i remember we sat there
10 because you know we we started to
realize magnus isn't where we actually
had his manager espanol decided in the
studio he said to us i don't think he
knows the rules and we counted down ten
nine and then he lost some time surreal
yeah happens to the best of us yeah so
we always need to read the rules
regulations
meanwhile there have been some
developments on the board and
i'm not so sure i like this for ding
so magnus found a way to trade off the
knights but in a really interesting way
so if we rewind just a few moves uh
we'll catch up with the current position
but here i thought white had full
control but magnus cleverly jumped in
with his knight
not only attacking the white queen but
also trying to undermine this glorious
piece on the outpost that we talked
about a bit earlier and
therefore ding had to trade off the
knights and black's rook got active and
maybe what ding had not realized is that
he cannot actually go and grab a pawn on
the edge of the board now because this
would walk into a simple double attack
they're coming across threatening some
checkmating ideas and threatening the
bishop and that forced him to just
weaken his position if he can't grab
this pawn he decided okay might as well
hit this brook kick it back and after
the rook stepped back he's trying to
initiate all these trades trying to take
off the pieces because as mentioned that
would favor white but now magnus has
actually gone for trades on his terms
he's brought the queen across he's
saying yes you can exchange but if you
trade the queens off now then there's a
problem white pawn in the corner here
are suddenly undefendable and uh there's
also tension with these rooks in the
center if we see a trade then for
example this type of position
suddenly i think it might favor black
this rook just too strong and if we see
a trade of black's backward pawn uh for
white's pawn here then suddenly black's
rook is more active of the two so
suddenly things are turning in whites in
black's favor sorry white is the one
having to be accurate and ding on the
defensive suddenly after this queen move
offering the trade he couldn't capture
as we showed so he just slides across
with his rook but he's lost a lot of
time he's retreated his bishop he's lost
two moves now with his rook and magnus
yeah he's got everything covered this
rook is doing an especially good job of
just protecting this backward pawn
yeah
it's impressive impressive play by
magnus um and the way that he's trying
to kind of change the nature of the
position i mean i honestly thought that
dean was just cruising for a small
advantage and it was going to be one
that was going to be plaguing magnus
until the very end but magnus know he's
turned it around and he's saying look
i have my dynamic possibilities and as
dave is highlighting there's a rook that
can go on an open line
white too has some weak pawns um as as
david has against highlighted and
yeah
i i agree with you it does feel like
black is better yeah or at least maybe
white's okay but white is the one having
to be more accurate and after this move
attacking this white b pawn i'm
expecting the pawn having to step up the
board there then
if magnus just wants to play safe and
just trade everything off uh this is
just very minimum this is a very typical
idea you just push this pawn forward and
it's always good to trade your isolated
pawns your weak pawns for your
opponent's strong pawns and here
this is just what we call a minority
attack this one pawn for black is
undermining two white pawns so we might
well see a situation where for example
there's a trade and uh yeah here white
has these weaknesses maybe even safer is
to just even trade the queens off and
then go after this weak white pawn
i think this position at the very
maximum is just going to be a draw for
white but maybe magnus in the current
position looking for even more because
the momentum as we mentioned is in his
favor so this is the safe option for
black using the rook going for that
minority attack pushing pawns trading
pawns but maybe he wants to keep the
queens on maybe we'll see him be a bit
more ambitious maybe push this pawn to
make quite a bit uncomfortable okay he
goes for the safe approach shuffling his
rook across let's go back to the players
can ding maintain the tension or is
magnus gonna neutralize him here that's
the question do you think magnus uh will
be happy with the draw in this game with
the black pieces
i think he wouldn't mind uh
maybe before the game he would have
loved the draw but the position he's got
maybe he's thinking oh some chances i
want to keep the game alive i want to
make doing a bit nervous
uh
yeah either way evaluation bar roughly
in the middle i think ding actually did
a good job we said things were turning
against him his last rook move just kind
of
just solidified everything and okay as
predicted that white pawn was under fire
and it had to step forward i'm expecting
magnus now to push his a pawn the
isolated pawn to undermine white's
structure on the left
is there any chance that
black can try to
switch the queen and the rook around
i mean that's what i would like to do
here because i feel that you know yeah i
trade in queens i like it it's safe it's
good but at the same time why is king
feels a little bit shaky yeah white's
king on this dark square diagonal it
feels like white's pushed the wrong pawn
in front of his king right
so yeah that would make a lot of sense
keeping the queens on i guess it's just
weighing up whether you can get an
attack quick enough as black against the
white king or whether your weakness is
the backward pawn that we mentioned on
the c6 where whether those kind of pawns
become
just too vulnerable before your attack
gets going
so yeah i mean i would be tempted to
move the black queen actually into the
a3 square maybe
yeah that's why i was thinking as well
why are you saying oh
like it's a scary move to me it is a
little bit scary because you know you
are kind of putting your queen
completely offside
and if white catches you unawares on the
right side of the board well okay but
the queens have
traded themselves off it was a bit of a
hypothetical question that we sell
ourselves but um
yeah
we're going to see that the line that
you mentioned where you know black has
a very pleasant position
yeah black does still have those
weaknesses but you can trade one of the
weaknesses off as mentioned when you
push your isolated pawn and then your
backward pawn it's easily dependable
it's not too big an issue here so
roughly balanced yeah do you actually
think that white's alone porn in the
middle of the board it's going to be a
real
problem
it could be a target right
possibly but at the moment it's easily
defended by white's work
yeah i mean
maybe he'll bring the white king closer
yeah what to say right now
it looks like uh just
sorry
but i could see you coughing so i put
some water to you david
and uh yeah definitely
something ding definitely has his
chances to play on he has a very
straightforward plan of improving his
pieces he needs to improve his light
square bishop and the first thing that i
would do is perhaps wait for black to
advance the pawn and then centralize the
king and
if he really wants to play it safe
start to uh
trade off a set of works
okay
well still a lot of time left on the
clocks for these two
and uh
it is sting thinking about what the move
to make remember we do have the auction
for that super successful gaming chair
secret lab gaming chair used by magnus
carlsen and the other players during the
tour finals
and now also by david owell when he beat
minus carlson at
10 years old and the current bid is
let's check you guys
current bid 620
one hour and 24 minutes left to make
your bid all the money goes to unicef
and the work
they're doing in and around ukraine
and this is a very unique chair first of
all it's a great gaming chair made by
secret lab i can confirm it's super
comfortable but also it has success
engraved in it by world champion magnus
carlson young chris of duda and hiri and
grandmaster david howell yeah oh and
jack it's off for digni ren it's getting
serious
it is getting serious okay and uh well
uh ding actually improving the light
squad bishop a little bit and uh magnus
stepping forward with his pawn and
operation trade-off has uh begun
yeah so as mentioned just
why not trade things off especially if
you have weak pawns
and two options here for ding
you can just take that pawn off the
board he goes for that that's the safer
option or you could have dropped back
the white light squad bishop but uh okay
now doing lifting his rooks and notice
how he's putting the rooks on the dark
squares where they can't be targets for
black's bishop
and uh okay white is the one with the
two isolated pawns now so it's time for
the kings to centralize themselves
it's a similar phase of the game that we
actually saw uh in game one where
the status quo was kind of maintained
for a while and both kings started
making their way towards the center
just in readiness in anticipation of the
rooks coming off and maybe a pawn race
later on the kings are essential pieces
right now and it's maybe easier for
black to improve his king than it is for
white white's king is kind of cut off
black's work on the e line just stopping
it from uh kind of moving over to the
left side of the board
but then again it's not exactly clear
where the black king is going either
so who would you take here imagine if
you had
had to choose a side if i have to take
sides because you're forcing me to i
would probably choose
the black black position feels more
familiar to me somehow i'm kind of you
know pawns on light squares light square
strategy it's something that i kind of
this could arise from yeah
exactly and uh i do really like how ding
has handled this though you know he's
mobilized his bishop and uh
the pawns sitting on a2 alice you know
she could be a liability but she could
also be a strength wow an interesting
decision taken by magnus here he's
offering a rook trade but it looks like
a
i mean it looks a bit odd if white takes
your rook now you get double pawns as
black i guess the idea is that white's
remaining rook is unable to really fight
against the pawns and this is where we
talk about breaking the rules by the top
players black's putting his rook here
allows this trade ruining his own pawn
structure these two pawns now really
really ugly but it's a kind of dynamic
thing it's just because on this next
move white is unable to stop this pawn
advancing if you could somehow magic the
white king over if you could kind of
plant it in front of this uh black pawn
then white is simply winning black's
pawns are just too ugly but here this
pawn just too strong so this trade was
not possible for ding really instructed
there by magnus and ding trying to get
in with his rook to the seventh rank
this has been met by magnus
pre-emptiness by bringing his king up
the board if white's rook tries to go
active now then black can simply
neutralize it by offering a trade and uh
yeah suddenly this black brook on an
active square still
and okay ding instead of going for a
rook trade brings us rick to the top of
the board he's gonna try and annoy black
from behind maybe with a check maybe by
going after some of the black pawns over
here and uh what about the uh plan of
pushing pawns
my favorite thing in the world alice
she wants to run to her destination i
mean how dangerous i mean
visually it looks very dangerous yeah
should black be worried
i mean if all the rooks suddenly came
off then definitely and uh
even with these two rooks right now
they're not actually ready they don't
look well positioned to stop the advance
of uh this a pawn as you mentioned
ivanka so maybe hin uh maybe hints of
ding pushing this pawn at least using
her as a distraction
uh while magnus has to worry about what
to do i don't think magnus can really
trade everything off here he wants to go
after just exchanges just swapping
things off maybe activating the black
king but this would allow for example a
nasty check and suddenly the black king
it can't step towards the white rook
because this would just lose a pawn or
two
in the center of the board and also if
you go to a light square there will be
consequences i'm imagining white bishop
coming forward uh or maybe you can just
capture a pawn in the center to open up
both white rooks against this pawn in
the center and the middle of the board
yeah
really awkward actually now suddenly for
magnus
i would have said black as well possibly
a couple of moves ago but just ding
positioning his pieces really actively
has caused some headaches for the world
champion this rook especially on its own
how do you deal with it how do you
contain it
it's just this is why we want rooks on
open files and here the rook's on a
completely open line and uh and it could
slide back at any moment it's just the
best piece in the position it's the star
player and black's rook meanwhile trying
to compete by activating itself but it's
hitting thin air unfortunately and it's
got less scope than whites does in the
corner but it's a smart move because i
can see that magnus is worried about the
pawn advance and so his idea is that
after the pawn advances rooks behind
pawn pass pawns yeah exactly and the
rook yeah that's really nice really
instructive guarding the pawn from
behind and suddenly
even if the white pawn continues to
advance at least the rook is trapped in
front of it so i don't think ding wants
to rush with that idea you don't want to
allow the black rook behind where it is
active
instead magnus in this position just
improves his bishop again the bishop did
come from here a couple of moves ago so
interesting the bishop's been kind of
yo-yoing back and forth and back and
forth and uh okay magnus it feels like
time to maybe improve this rook this
rook i praised it a while ago regarding
the sixth rank but
it's done its job there maybe it's time
to slide it back and try to bring it to
other open files and uh game two between
duda and liam ended in a draw meaning
duda is still up by one point and
actually if he wins game three he will
be ready for the final in the charity
cup liam he will need at least the draw
in the next game but with the white
pieces we know he's gonna be going for
the win in that game and uh hopefully
we're gonna have time to go to that as
well well we will have time to see that
game as well because uh this one do you
think it's gonna be as long as the first
game
in terms of moves we had 110 moves in
the first game
it's possible i mean it's going to be a
long one i mean it's rare to see any
game reach move 100
maybe one in every 20 games gets there
but
if that but
still a lot of life left in this one
yeah and it's all about the pawn
imbalances the pieces look roughly
similar rooks bishops they just kind of
balance each other out but white has
this past porn as we mentioned the a
pawn and black's two versus one in the
center
less effective right now but could also
become a become a factor so
yeah still a lot of life left both sides
have reason to be hopeful if black can
pick off white central isolated pawn to
black will win if white's pawn can run
up the board the a pawn white's going to
be in charge
yeah i'm still struggling to decide who
i'd rather be here ah it's just that
kind of position there's pros and cons
for both sides it's just about who can
maneuver better in this end game usually
we would say that's magnus but the
reason magnus fears ding or respect
sting is because ding is equally good in
this type of position ah yeah and end
games yeah i mean universal i mean yeah
we actually saw it yesterday in his end
game the night end game against jordan
van forest i mean it started off as a
level end game and then you know dang
with not so much time left on the clock
actually started playing
very accurately and found some really
nice ways to secure a victory and
yeah i mean i i think david is totally
right i mean here the position depends
on who is going to maneuver in the best
way and for me i also agree with david
the rook
sitting on the e6 square it's not
working it needs to do something and i
would be even tempted to try and find
ways to trade it off
yeah
that would make a lot of sense you would
love to also trade it off for this white
rook in the corner exactly just that
white rook is just too annoying on every
turn the reason magnus is actually
spending so long and going low on the
clock is because on every turn you have
to calculate that white rook coming
across with a check or hitting some
pawns and okay wow blacks rooks really
intruding into white's half now and
they've ganged up on the third row maybe
hinting at going across to that
a file to block white's passport over
there yeah and trade off rooks which is
what we wanted
yeah and magnus finding a very creative
way how to achieve this
really logical just aesthetically we're
not used to seeing this type of setup
with the black rooks no
just visually it looks a bit odd and
unusual but it could be effective and as
you mentioned there's a clear plan in
mind and that's normally a sign that a
move is good if there's a clear
follow-up plan
so yeah back to
back to white deciding whether to push
pawns whether to give checks with that
white rook at the top of the board
if you want to move it where to
white's bishop at the moment and the
rook on the second rank not really
helping and not really coordinating with
that rock in the corner
yeah
and uh whilst we're waiting for ding to
come up with a plan because it looks
like he's uh wasn't expecting that move
and he was a little bit surprised um i'd
like to share with you one quick selfie
by cherry puffling oh and he does
make a commitment and he pushes alice
the a pawn and uh well suddenly
the moves have come thick and fast and
the pawn has suddenly found its way from
a2 all the way up to the sixth row wow
in seconds yeah we talked about my game
having three seconds left earlier
against magnus age 10 but literally
within three seconds that white pawn
went from the second rank to the sixth
rank it's as if it just hopped up uh
meanwhile black just maneuvering his
rooks that white horn still could
advance one square further but at least
it's got a black rook behind it keeping
an eye on its advance this is really
scary for magnus though because that
white pawn on the sixth rank is also
defended by its bishop so the white rook
can still swing across and
actually black is a bit stuck one of
your rooks is going to be paralyzed
forever guarding the advance of that
pawn
and yeah the evaluation bar not too
excited but from a human point of view
this is huge progress on ding's part
he's made a huge leap with that pawn
oh that looks scary it is magnus it is
scary uh it is like visually it it
totally is um
when you kind of step back and you're a
little bit ice cold about it i don't
think it's that scary because blacks
rook keep a watchful eye under over that
pawn having said that it's very
difficult for ding to find a plan and
it's also very difficult for magnus to
do the same yeah and just to mention uh
so in this position white would love to
push this pawn forward for example he
could have pushed it on the last go and
some viewers at home might be wondering
why can't this pawn step forward next
move if black is careless for example
then the rook will come across with a
check the king will move and then you
promote you make a new queen defended by
the rook and you actually win one of
black's rooks in the process but the
answer would have been no you really
shouldn't push this pawn forward yet you
needed your bishop to keep defending it
because once you push forward the black
king is actually going to step back and
now no more checks for this white rook
this rook cannot go anywhere wherever
you move it this black pawn will drop
for example actually you can swing it
across
but this would just result in an
exchange and black would have got rid of
that important a pawn so in the current
position if we catch up with the game we
saw white just being a bit more patient
notice how keeping his pawn on the
square covered by its bishop and uh just
giving a check as well with the white
rook so now if the king the black king
does move away and continue guarding its
pawns i think white's idea was to go
after this backward pawn that we've been
talking about for most of the game
instead magnus preventing this idea by
dropping his bishop back walking into a
pin but at least cutting off the access
of the white rook to the other half of
the board and uh still
yet to find a winning plan for ding it's
still looking good for him visually for
white but this pawn under locking key
for now
wow
and uh i wonder if dingley ren is able
to win this game if he's going to have a
huge celebration like david had when
winning against magnus 10 i did see in
comments on our
chess champs on twitter a lot of
appreciation for seeing that kind of joy
after a great win
yeah and we also had did have a request
that david next time he beats magnus age
10 does a christian ronaldo
victory what's the soup
[Laughter]
nobody wants to see that
then we're talking celebrations and i
have a suspicion that david's reaction
might be
making its way into a meme
nice
i know what our viewers are like that's
definitely going to happen why did you
say that you're like
oh
yeah i love that celebration i mean it's
power
i loved it
maybe we'll see a celebration from one
of these two uh if they win because it
is that big a matchup i can hardly
imagine though dingley ran celebrating
like i mean we have seen it for magnus
actually when he won was it the ftx
crypto cup against wesley so in
armageddon huge celebration yeah looked
like he was about to rip off his shirt
yeah
yeah it actually did
but yeah dingley ran doesn't strike me
as the type
not outwardly no i yeah i think i might
we might have seen him do
we've seen him smile
maybe maybe his fist pumps no not the
same as streaming footage my favorite
reaction was the flowers
i'm david navarro yeah that was totally
unexpected and very very sweet yeah when
he won against magnus in the
preliminaries yeah and actually one of
the most emotional moments i've had from
just watching chess purely was at the
world cup a few years ago when ding lost
the final of the world cup and uh he
just went to sit in the corner just kind
of
you could see the emotion on him he was
trying to hide his tears hide his
disappointment but
yeah i mean that's one of the first
times i just on someone's behalf i
thought oh yeah this is really sad and
uh
yeah it would be nice to see i mean
after such a difficult couple of years
for him unable to play travel uh nice to
see him have a few good results this
coming year well and definitely anger is
something we can see in chess after um
some losses definitely in the milwaukee
champions chester i remember once seeing
the pognyacci throw his mouse into the
wall
i also remember it was a rapid and blitz
world championship in berlin
magnus just threw a pen that was
actually over-the-board chats yeah i
remember that because my hairdressers
all commented and i said we didn't like
that behavior from magnus can you
imagine even having that conversation
with your hairdresser but in norway you
can yeah um chess is that popular
and uh yeah it's yeah definitely we have
seen reactions i've seen a rook being
thrown
really yeah who was that
yeah
it wasn't her finest moment
i do like the big reactions
all right some moves is ding well okay
the bar is now over to minus the side
yeah um i think the bar just yet to make
up his decision because it is still
roughly balanced but ding really going
for it uh he's trying to initiate
something
if white just wanted to sit he would
have done but look at white's last pawn
push okay black moving the rook back if
white's pawn had been captured by
black's bishop the white rook would have
slid across on the seventh rank and
captured a pawn if that pawn the white f
pawn would have been captured by a pawn
the black h-pawn would have dropped off
so white's pawn there actually it looks
like just a fearless
footsoldier just running up the board
but it could not actually be captured
safely
it would have just resulted in a trade
so ding actually trying to open up some
lines trying to get some action uh he's
already dominant now on the left side of
the board with his a pawn he's trying to
create a second avenue of attack but
magnus is saying no he's locking things
down and his rook retreat actually
completely kind of cages white's rook on
the a7 square it can only move out now
with an exchange it's no longer the
active piece it previously was so really
interesting it's still hard to call and
wow ding that's a huge commitment this
is either going to be a genius move that
wins the game for white later
or it's going to be something that ding
lipstick will regret because this pawn
push
ivanka that pawn is weak that pawn is
weak
very very weak all could drop off later
in the game you could envisage not yet
but later black's king just stepping
across and picking off this white pawn
that has just moved
so so ding is actually just using
tactical tricks
to keep that pawn safe so his idea is if
black dis does try to be greedy so for
instance moves the king around to the
middle of the board to attack the knight
then maybe
moves such as uh pushing the g pawn two
squares forward
will start uh troubling black because
you can't capture the pawn because after
bishop takes pawn whoops you drop a
bishop
so that's not possible
and if you're allowing this pawn move
then you're going to allow white to set
up that pawn chain that is the dream
and wow magnus is no way
really surprising he's actually trying
to provoke white to achieve something
maybe he wanted to do anyway and look at
the evaluation bar it shot up for ding
and it might be down to this move
ivanka's highlighted pushing this pawn
forward this pawn is taboo you can't
capture it and also remember you can't
capture this pawn either it's poisoned
because suddenly the black bishop would
drop off white's king white the black
king sorry it was tied down defending
his bishop and wow ding didn't go for
this opportunity pushing a pawn forward
this looked very very uh kind of simple
and pretty strong and he didn't go for
it he offers the trade of rooks instead
and the available evaluation bar drops
back down so maybe a moment of both
sides just semi-bluffing there and uh
ding not wanting to commit his pawns now
a rook trade would i think favor white
slightly because suddenly again the
black king unable to capture this pawn
needs to defend his bishop and black's
active rook has disappeared instead
magnus keeps the rooks on the board
trying to create some counter play using
this pin
i think ding has been very very clever
because you know he's offered a trade
which magnus couldn't accept
and now look at it he's mobilized his
rook the rook is primed to join its
siblings
yep it's primed to join its sibling onto
the seventh row
check and then seventh rank yep and uh
also you know you still have this idea
of uh pushing the g pawn two squares
forward in reserve you've got it in your
pocket as you say
it
feels really quite dangerous like magnus
is living a little bit on the edge
yeah really scary now for magnus to
survive it looks like ding with this
rook check and bring it to the seventh
rank
creating some real winning chances
all right
and magnus uh one minute and uh 43
seconds left ding one well two minutes
left now um how hard will this be to
play for magnus if he now takes under
the minute
is it's going to be it's going to be a
dramatic game because you know
driving that rook down to the seventh
row that is a kind of committal decision
because the rook could get caught on the
seventh
it could have been trapped so black has
uh moved his bishop one square along the
diagonal rather than offering this
bishop trade um
wow both sides both sides yeah there's
actually a trap uh at some point if the
black bishop ever leaves the diagonal if
for example the black bishop captures
the white bishop white's rook now will
actually slide across two squares and
checkmate the black king the d7 square
just the one behind the black king that
one needs to be guarded by black's
bishop otherwise it's just checkmate in
this end game so yeah right now also
tension between these two rooks would
you capture ivanka would you trade off
one set of rooks
those two white rooks together look
fantastic on the seventh rank
but if you trade off now with black that
rook is replaced by white pawn right
aporn alice will become a b pawn and one
square away from promotion
yes it's hang on a second we have a a
little bit of a
do you have to go do you have to
that's the big question if you move the
black rook away that black rook is going
to end up on a terrible square
there's still we should mention a pin on
the second rank so white's bishop cannot
move right now uh it's pinned to its
king but yeah suddenly magnus look at
this he has captured the rook that is
ice cold just uh decision making
now the white pawn is gonna take back
what else is there for ding okay he
showed a bit of frustration there maybe
he thought he was winning on the spot
but black's rook can guard this pawn for
now and now black is threatening bishop
takes bishop yeah forcing the white rook
to leave the defense of its b pawn and
uh ding has lost the pawn yeah i will
maybe dink can preserve his pawn by
making a new queen here distracting the
black rook from the second ranked pin
but that would be a bad sign
uh that would mean that he's fighting
for the draw
suddenly yeah he has to do that that's
the only way it's the only way he has to
promote that white b-pawn it's so
counter-intuitive not obvious for a
human that's your pride and joy that
white pawn now one square away from
promotion you actually have to give it
up right now
ah because otherwise you might just lose
the game because otherwise as ivanka
mentioned you're pinned with your bishop
you can't move your bishop he does make
a new queen he had to release the
tension with the bishops and uh okay
after that transition white giving up
the pawn the bishop trade white has
actually also managed to regain the pawn
himself with a rook so now it's
it's anyone's game still this end game
it looks like it should be a draw
according to the computer but look at
the pawn structure it's really
imbalanced white still has a pawn on the
sixth rank black has doubled pawns black
has a two versus one advantage in the
center it's imbalanced still oh it's a
crazy rook and porn ending because you
know if
magnus really wants to spice things up
one sting runs with his king say he
chooses to run with his king to the
right
well the black rook is going to go after
the pawn in the middle of the board and
oh he hasn't gone for this he could have
maybe gone for the win here magnus but
this would have entailed a lot of risk
instead he's moving towards this far
advanced white pawn and he's hoping that
uh if the rook moves out the way then at
the very least he can just capture it
and remove white's remaining winning
chances here for example i think black
is active enough okay we're going for
this position battle act is active
enough going for white's pawn in the
center to hold the draw it's still
anyone's game but it looks like the
players have found a way to both at
least remove some risk wow
and uh game three between liam and
anyone chris of duda has just started um
if duda wins that game he's gonna be
ready for his very first mouthwater
champions chess tour final liam needs at
least a draw and he has to win either
this game or the next one to uh take it
to tie breaks
we will jump into that game when this
one finishes
but could it be a long game still yup it
could be still but uh with this last
move it's looking like maybe ding has
found a way to just eliminate another
couple of pawns
the more pawns that disappear the less
likely it becomes that we'll be uh with
this game for too long so now i'm
expecting black's rook to give a check
you always want to drive your opponent's
king back to passivity the white's king
was nicely placed on the third rank
drive it away so that check was
important and now black defends his own
pawn and we might see the end of this
game any moment yep there are repeating
nothing else to do black defends the
pawn gives a check three-fold repetition
it's a draw both of them shaking their
heads they look like magnus is going to